hello my name is Dustin Kirkland I'm a
product manager at Google and I'm joined
here by Ricardo Rocha Ricardo gave a
keynote from his experience as a
computer engineer at CERN IT working on
the Higgs boson experiment Ricardo can
you give us maybe a short recap of your
keynote right so the initial goal that
we had when we first came here was to
try to reproduce the analysis that
actually ended up being a Nobel Prize
gave a Nobel Prize to to some physicists
which is the discovery of the Higgs
boson and we wanted to really do the
analysis using new technologies
kubernetes and other cloud native
technologies the initial experiment the
initial analysis was done in 2012 or
just before and announced in just a year
after and we had to use a lot of
computing resources and we just wanted
to show how much easier it is using like
more recent technologies after a couple
of years so the initial analysis takes
hours or even a day and we wanted to do
it in three minutes so that was the goal
I was quite challenging but actually
works so it was pretty awesome three
minutes to reproduce the results of the
original Higgs boson experiment yeah so
initially we were trying to target
because we had a 20-minute slot so we
started targeting at 15 minutes and then
we realized that actually using
with the help of the cool cloud we could
Google faster so we ended up doing it
like 3-4 minutes Wow can you give us
just a sense of some of the differences
between running that sort of compute on
Prem on your own infrastructure versus
running in a hosted cloud with Google so
it just changes our focus like and we
have a large data center but large in
the sense of like science of course like
if you look at Facebook or Google or all
this big cloud cloud providers it's
different scale so in in our own
environment we know it very well we know
how to tune for it but we also have to
spend a lot of time maintaining these
resources when you go to the public
cloud to the Google cloud we focus more
on learning the details but we don't
have to focus so much on the
infrastructure we can focus more on the
application which is kind of a benefit
for us so you can be in a higher level
focus right so you can spend your time a
bit more and your investment a bit more
on the experiments and the data itself
rather than managing the infrastructure
right yeah that's exactly it there's
still some advantages to have our own
data center for some of the workloads
because they are very close to the
experiments so the experiments are
basically on on-site so we can pull
links and have very fast links and
process the data very fast low latency
but for a lot of our workloads at going
to the public cloud allows us to burst
also for extra capacity when we need it
and focus more on the application side
can you give us just a sense of the
amount of resources you need for this
experiment CPUs memory disk you know you
can till this time but you know the
other the other other bits right so the
experiments are generating something
like one petabyte a second which is way
too much so we have this Hardware
triggers filters and software filters
and we reduce to something like 10g
like ii that's what we're storing so in
total we are generating 70 petabytes a
year of new data and that we have to
analyze and in-house we have around
300,000 cores but then we use a
distributed computing environment where
we double that so we need something like
700,000 cores to process all this data
yeah so that's roughly in in-house we
have total of 400 petabytes of storage
this breakup Wow Wow
give us a sense of what's coming next
maybe something another experiment or
how you you plan to use the on-prem
versus the Google cloud infrastructure
in the future
so that's a very exciting for us because
the accelerator is now during an upgrade
phase and we'll have one more run but
then what's coming next is much more
exciting we call it the high luminosity
LHC and the reason it's high luminosity
it's actually because we generate a lot
more collision so a lot more data we are
increasing the amount of data we have to
process by a hundred times and right now
we don't really know how we'll manage
all of this both on the storage side and
computing so investing a lot in machine
learning and learning how to use better
GPUs and potentially TP use and of
course because we have a limited amount
of resources in-house we are looking a
lot to explain to the public clouds to
have more resources but also to be able
to use new technologies like TP news and
things like this it's very exciting
and last question can you give us a
sense of which of the Google cloud
products you were making use of here
right so we based most like the world
deployment on DKE
for for kubernetes manage kubernetes but
we actually also used Google Cloud
Storage to host the data and we were
reading from it and then we had to
publish the results at CERN we were
using reddit so at Google Cloud we're
raising
Souths memory store which is the
equivalent so we kind of spent a lot
yeah we could even do more probably
Ricardo this is fascinating thank you so
much